l'une des îles de riou au large de
marseille a été acheté par le
conservatoire du littoral il s'agit de
préserver la faune et la flore et pour
être sûr qu'aucun campeurs ou touristes
indélicats ne viennent les détériorer
les gardiens veillent jour et nuit
ils sont alors seuls sur leur île y
compris le vendredi
sorte de robinson crusoé des temps
modernes jacques cardoze longtemps
déserté longtemps préservé voilà un
ancien patrimoine militaire dont un à
manta aujourd'hui la charge depuis 1992
cet archipel de rio a en effet été placé
sous la responsabilité du conservatoire
du littoral
objectif tenter de préserver un site que
l'homme a oublié de coloniser pour le
plus grand bonheur de la nature pas
facile un week-end de 15o on a plus de
50 bateaux de la glace thériault c'est
une des coups de trique facilement
accessible dès l'île de riou l'argoat
romain que le sida est surpris quand on
sait qu'il y en a des candidats l'île
déserte des candidats au rêve mais tous
sont surveillés de près pas question de
plaisanter avec une biodiversité unique
à l'île de riou d'ailleurs alain vente
va plus loin il a mis en place depuis
deux ans une surveillance accrue
l'heureuse élue vie dans cette cabane
nuitées jour je restais sur l'île
pendant quatre jours environ
le matin je me réveille vers 8 heures
j'ai déjà et après je pars faire les
rondes vous sentez un peu
robinson et surtout le soir dès que vers
5-6 heures ou war 7h ou qui intéresse
les nous trois derniers qu'on les voit
partir
en attendant cette solitude eric
consacre sa journée à surveiller le
comportement de ces visiteurs d'un jour
d'une crique à l'autre eric explique
qu'il est interdit de faire des
barbecues du bivouac ou de sortir des
sentiers et tout cela bien sûr à une
explication l'archipel de riou est un
site sur lequel on trouve au 18 espèces
végétales protégées
c'est un site c'est le seul un des seuls
sites en france où on trouve trois
espèces de otto marins ne posera reform
zozos qui vivent à tenir toute l'année
qui vient se reproduire les plus fins et
les pétrels
du coup c'est il serait presque un musée
pour certains scientifiques alors l'île
de riou espère devenir réserve naturelle
afin d'être définitivement à l'abri de
toute convoitise